(delicate piano music)
- [Narrator] In the
Indian state of Manipur
you will find Keibul Lamjao National Park-
the world's only floating
wildlife sanctuary.
(moving piano music)
Keibul Lamjao comprises
over 15 square miles
of rich, biodiverse wetlands,
and includes Loktak Lake,
the largest freshwater
lake in northern India.
The park is known for
patches and rings of biomass
that float on the surface of the wetlands.
The floating vegetation, called phumdis,
thrives in the park, creating a home
for humans and animals alike.
(moving orchestral music)
The endangered sangai, a
subspecies of brow-antlered deer,
are only found in the park.
They have been called the binding soul
between humans and nature.
The sangai was believed
to be nearing extinction
in the 1950s, but thanks to
aggressive conservation efforts
their numbers have steadily
increased to more than 200.
Still relatively unknown
outside the region,
Keibul Lamjao National Park is truly
one of India's hidden gems.
(delicate piano music)